dans le cadre de la campagne d'éducation
des shadoks que nous avions promis au
début de notre feuilleton à l'oasis que
nous prenons pour de logique shadok
professeur jadot au programme les
passoires
on n'appelle pas soir tout instrument
sur lequel on peut définir trois
sous-ensembles l'intérieur l'extérieur
et les coûts l'intérieur est
généralement placés au dessus de
l'extérieur et se compose le plus
souvent de nouilles et dont les trous ne
sont pas importants en effet une
expérience simple permet de se rendre
compte que l'on ne change pas
notablement les qualités de l'instrument
en réduisant de moitié le nombre des
trous puis en réduisant cette moitié de
moitié etc etc et à la limite jusqu'à ce
qu'il n'y ait plus de trous de tous tout
théorème la notion de passoire est
indépendante de la notion de trous et
les six propre mans